5 26 on your wednesday morning we
learned the other day that more and more
of us are at least owning up to texting
and driving here's an update on
dangerous distractions that can lead to
fatal crashes
fisher from the governor's highway
safety association we need to educate
the public about the fact that these are
real people who are dying these are
mom's dads sisters brothers tricia
morrow from general motors says we're
learning more about why we do these
things when we know we shouldn't
distraction is more than just texting
and driving distraction can be
eating in your vehicle it can also
involve elements of emotional stress if
a driver is under severe
emotional stress that they can be almost
10 times more likely to get into a crash
we're killing people every day on our
roads and most of these crashes are the
result of behaviors that can be
prevented
there you have it i want to say thank
you to everyone who thanks me when i'm
out and about around town for saying
buckle up drive carefully and yeah put
down that phone something driving you
crazy email me traffic 8 8newsnow.com